PROFESSOR: All right, now for
something completely different.
Before beginning though,
I would like to raise a
procedural question.
It was my intent that quiz
number two, which is like a
little more than a week away,
was going to be part symmetry
and part tensors.
I don't want to have your
fortunes based by weight of
2:1 on symmetry theory as
opposed to properties.
What I would suggest, and you
can express your opinion
either way, is that we postpone
quiz number two by
maybe as much as 10 days, so
that it can be half symmetry
and half the introductory
discussion of tensors.
And if that does not create a
conflict with some of your
other classes, I would propose
that as a suggestion.
If not, we can just have on the
quiz what we're going to
cover of tensors in the
next couple days and
have the rest symmetry.
So what I am suggesting is the
quiz was scheduled for a week
from November 8, which
is a Tuesday.
What I would suggest is putting
that off to the 18th,
and that will give us four
extra lectures--
six extra lectures-- on tensors
and we can make the
quiz 50-50.
AUDIENCE: What does that do
to quiz number three?
PROFESSOR: Quiz number three
is going to stay in place
because it's right at
the end of the term.
AUDIENCE: What about the
subject in three?
PROFESSOR: It will
be all tensors.
It will be all tensors
and properties.
And the third quiz is set up
for longer than you think.
It's December 8, so it'll
be about three weeks.
AUDIENCE: So everything
from here on?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Does that make sense?
Or is somebody going to have a
big, traumatic responsibility
at that point?
AUDIENCE: I don't know, but I
think it would be probably be
easiest for us not to
have it three days
before close of exams.
PROFESSOR: OK, OK, that's
what I wanted to hear.
How about if we went just a
little bit further then and
did it not on the--
when was the suggestion?
The 18th.
Let's say we did it on
Tuesday the 15th?
Does that conflict
with anything?
AUDIENCE: That's a little bit.
AUDIENCE: We were doing
it on the 18th.
AUDIENCE: Is that Friday?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry, 18th.
I said it would be 17th.
Excuse me.
AUDIENCE: That definitely would
be a little better.
PROFESSOR: OK, let me allow you
to think about that, and
that would be pushing it back
one week and maybe it'd be--
we'll see how much material
on tensors we cover.
So let's table it for now but
let's say, tentatively, let's
consider seriously moving
it to the 15th.
OK?
But you guys have final
say if there's a
preference that you have.
OK let's talk about properties
in first a general and rather
philosophic way.
When we discuss properties we
very commonly lump together a
set of behaviors which have
some common phenomenology.
So for example, we will talk
about mechanical properties.
And that's a basket in which we
place many different sorts
of behavior.
We place things like fracture
toughness, yield strength,
elastic constants, a whole
variety of things involving
strength deformation
and so on.
Or another thing we very often
lump together in a basket is
something called electrical
properties.
And we talk about electrical
conductivity, ionic
conductivity, electronic
conductivity.
We talk about dielectric
constants, we talk about
permittivity and permeability,
magnetic properties--
a whole bunch of other classes
of behavior, which have some
sort of root or description in
terms of electromagnetism.
There are though a lot of
strange aspects to properties.
There are some properties that
are determined for material
which no longer exists
when you're through
determining the property.
You have a sample you want
to know what the
yield strength is.
So you put the gradually
increasing load on it until
finally, POP, it breaks.
And now you know what the
yield strength is for a
material that no
longer exists.
Another example is an old one.
Back before the days of X-ray
diffraction when people would
try to characterize material,
anything that is very
intensely colored usually looks
black, and that's not a
very definitive property.
The color of something is a very
prominent characteristic.
So for mineralogists, in
particular, anybody going out
into the hills and wanting to be
prepared to determine what
a particular rock that they
tripped over was had something
on a rope around their neck
called a streak plate.
And what the streak plate
was was a little
rectangle of porcelain.
And they would take this black
mineral and rub it on this
piece of porcelain and it
would leave a mark--
that was called the streak.
And what this was was actually
little bunch of fragments that
rubbed off on to the porcelain
because the porcelain was
white and the fragments
were very small.
A black piece of rock could
give you a streak that was
brown or green or deep orange.
And so you really were
determining the color of the
material when it was in a form
finely divided enough that
light could pass through it.
So the streak test was a very
important diagnostic for
determining minerals.
There are some properties
that we refer to
as structure sensitive.
In the sense that
their value--
conductivity is a
good example--
the value of ionic conductivity
depends on the
impurities and point
defects that are
present in the material.
So to say that the ionic
conductivity of a certain
material is such and such, you
have to specify the purity and
perfection of the material or
the property's meaningless.
There are some properties that
are not even single-valued.
And the best example there are
dielectric or magnetic
properties.
If you plot the magnetization
of a material, the magnetic
moment per unit volume as a
function of the applied
magnetic field B, the material
is initially non-magnetized.
When you apply B, you get a
magnetic moment per unit
volume that eventually
saturates.
And then if you remove the
magnetic field, the material
keeps some of its
magnetization.
It doesn't go to zero when you
reduce the field to zero.
You have to reverse the field
to get the property to go to
zero and then magnetize it
in another direction.
And if you continue to cycle the
magnetic field, you get a
behavior like this.
This is hysteresis, and this
type of behavior is called
generally hysteretic.
Same thing would be a relation
between the displacement
vector and an applied
electric field.
But clearly you can have any
value of the magnetization in
this range.
And if you relate the
magnetization as a function of
the applied field, you can
get any value of the
proportionality constant you
like between a negative
maximum and a positive maximum
including zero.
So there's a property that's
not even single-valued.
Depends on the past history
of the sample.
And then there are even more
peculiar properties.
There are properties
that are--
we call them composite
properties and very often
qualitative.
What do they mean by a
composite property.
Let me give you one example--
The property fuzzy.
If I say fuzzy, you know
exactly what I mean.
It means something that has
a diffuse reflectivity,
something that has a surface
texture that's yielding.
It's not like rubbing
a wire brush.
It's soft and giving, a whole
collection of different
properties.
But yet when I say fuzzy, you
know exactly what I mean.
Let me not be so facetious
as talking
about a fuzzy property.
People such as ceramists or
powder metallurgists very
often will take a powder of a
material and consolidate it by
compacting it and heating it,
very often subject to a
compacting stress.
And when you do that little
necks grow between the
particles and they
hold together and
the material is centric.
So you refer to a property of
a powder as being centerable
or the centerability
of a powder.
You know exactly what somebody
means by that.
But what does it depend on?
It depends on the surface
energy, it depends on vapor
pressure, depends on bulk
diffusion coefficients.
It depends on surface diffusion
coefficients.
And all of these things have to
be just right to make the
powder something that easily
densifies upon heating in the
application or not
of pressure.
So you know exactly what I mean
by centerability, but it
is a very complex property.
And was one that really was not
understood until probably
the late 1950s.
Until then, it was an art that
was entirely empirical.
And it was somebody here at
MIT, a fellow named Robert
Coble, who developed a theory
of centering that was the
first really workable theory
that described densification
by heating and compaction.
OK, composite property that
depends on many different
individual properties
of the material.
OK, what we are going to examine
here are equilibrium
properties that can be
rigorously defined and
measurable.
So we're going to leave out of
the picture things like fuzzy
and centerability.
And let me give a very nice,
obscure definition of what I
mean by a property.
And what I mean by a property,
in terms of a formal
statement, is the response of
a material to a specific
change in a given set
of conditions.
So the response of the material
to a specific change
in a set of conditions that
relates independent properties
and dependent properties for
a particular process.
So I'll state that again
because I think
it's terribly elegant.
So a property is the response of
the material to a specific
change in a given set of
conditions that relates
independent and dependent
quantities in
a particular process.
Now there are a lot of
properties that have their
roots solidly embedded
in thermodynamics.
So let me give you
a few of those.
What we'll talk about when
we specify a property is
something that we will refer
to as a displacement.
We'll talk about a generalized
displacement in response to a
generalized force.
So some of the thermodynamic
quantities that are related in
this fashion--
if we list some forces and some
displacements, the thing
that happens as a result of that
stimulus that's applied
to the material.
Temperature can be regarded as
a force that results in all
sorts of processes
as a result--
thermal energy flow,
thermal expansion,
all sorts of things.
But one of the things that will
happen in response to a
temperature change
thermodynamically is an entropy.
So you can view entropy as a
generalized displacement
resulting from the application
of temperature as a
generalized force.
Another example is electric
field and the thing that
happens there, and
electromagnetism, is the
quantity, D, which
is displacement.
Still another example, stress,
and the result of applying a
stress, among other things,
is a strain.
What is special about these
forces in this displacement is
that their product is, in each
of these cases, energy, the
change in internal energy
of the particular body.
And when that is the case,
these are said to be
conjugate--
a conjugate force and
displacement.
And there are other examples
that one can come up .with.
Now to talk about a specific
set of properties.
Very often, and this crept into
the earlier discussion,
very often the thing that we
do to a material, as a
generalized force,
is a vector.
So very often the thing that we
do to the material, apply
an electric field, apply a
magnetic field, apply a
temperature gradient, apply a
tensile stress, it has the
characteristics of a vector,
magnitude and direction.
And in many cases, the thing
that happens as a generalized
displacement, we may call
this in general,
q, is also a vector.
An example is if we apply
an electric field as a
generalized force, one thing
that might happen is a current
flow, which is also a vector.
And we are accustomed to
writing, q, the generalized
displacement, as a
proportionality constant,
sigma, which is in the case of
electric field and current
flow, the electrical
conductivity.
Let me call it, in general
terms, proportionality
constant, a, times the
applied vector, p.
Is this something we would
like to stick with as a
general relation?
Well let me submit that writing
an expression of this
form makes an inherent
assumption.
Namely that this will be true
for small, and we'll have to
define for each property
what we mean by a
small, applied vector.
Let me give you an example.
If p were--
the applied vector was electric
field, and the
resulting vector was current
flow, and the relation between
those is the conductivity--
a relation of this sort says
that if you double the field,
you double the conductivity.
You triple the field, you
triple the conductivity.
Obviously this can't go on
indefinitely because all a
sudden, POW, dielectric
breakdown.
The sample evaporates
at the smoke.
And again, you have the property
of a material which
no longer exists.
So a lot of properties, we
inherently assume that the
applied vector is small in order
to write something in an
expression of this form.
So for conductivity, dielectric
breakdown is going
to destroy the nice linear
relation between current flow
and electric field.
That's not always the case.
Let me give you an example
of another property.
And this is a property, magnetic
susceptibility, which
relates the magnetization, which
is magnetic moment per
unit volume, and relates that to
an applied electric field--
an applied magnetic field, H.
And the proportionality
constant, represented by a Greek
chi, is the magnetic
susceptibility.
So let me give you a
specific example.
Suppose we have a chunk of glass
and the glass contains a
dilute concentration of iron.
And iron carries a permanent
magnetic moment.
And the reason I want to make
it a dilute concentration of
iron is I don't want these
magnetic moments close enough
that they can interact
with one another.
I want this to, therefore,
be a dilute system.
So we have different
iron atoms in this.
Each iron atom has a
magnetic moment.
And then we put this in a
magnetic field, H. And the
magnetic field acts on each of
these little magnetic moments
just as though it were
a compass needle.
And so it will try to take each
of these moments and drag
it into coincidence with
the magnetic field.
But at a finite temperature,
temperatures making these
magnetic moments jiggle
around, so at a finite
temperature, the magnetic
moments will just not simply
zing into coincidence with
the magnetic field.
You'll have to increase
the magnetic
field to make it larger.
When that happens, more and more
of the magnetic moments
will come into alignment.
And if you put on a really
strong magnetic field, then
every single magnetic moment
will be dragged into exact
alignment with the magnetic
field and
the system has saturated.
There's no way you could squeeze
further magnetic
moment per unit volume
out of it.
So again, you would expect, for
this particular property,
magnetic susceptibility of a
material, if you plot it as a
function of the applied
magnetic field--
linear maybe be at low
applied fields--
but eventually if you make the
field strong enough, the
system is going to saturate.
And then again, no longer will
the direction of the
magnetization, and that magnetic
moment, be parallel
to H. But the property becomes
nonlinear if the applied
vector is strong enough.
This is an example of a property
where you would not
go wrong at all by stating
direct proportionality.
For ordering to occur,
temperature and applied field
go hand in hand.
Increased temperature tends
to create more disorder.
Increased magnetic field tends
to align the moments.
In the days when MIT had a
national magnet laboratory,
the magnet laboratory held the
record for the strongest
magnetic field ever produced
artificially by man.
And if you took that magnetic
field and applied it to this
system of dilute iron in a
glass, you would have to lower
the temperature of the sample
to about 3 Kelvin before you
would begin to see saturation.
So even the strongest field that
you could produce in a
laboratory environment would
not succeed in producing
non-linearity until you cooled
the sample down almost to
absolute zero.
So here would be a case where
under any practical
consideration whatsoever,
assumption of strict
proportionality would be
right on the money.
You'd be absolutely correct.
But there's another assumption
built into this statement.
P, the generalized force, is
a vector in the cases we're
discussing now, and q
is also a vector.
So when we write an expression
of this form you're making
another assumption.
And that is that the vector
displacement that results is
always exactly parallel to the
vector that you apply.
Do I make a big deal
out of this?
Isn't that always going
to be the case?
I mean whoever heard of taking
a piece of metal and putting
an electric field on it in this
direction and having the
current run off in
this direction.
It's absurd.
Or maybe it isn't so absurd.
So let's think of some of the
atomistics of this process.
Now, since I know I'm among
friends, I will not hesitate
to display my ignorance, total
ignorance, of polymer chemistry.
So suppose we had a
piece of polymer.
That's what a polymer
molecule looks like.
It's a more or less linear
molecule, and so these might,
in a very highly ordered
polymer, be chains that lined
up like this.
And suppose we now put an
electric field on this polymer
and asked how the current
will flow.
Again, it would not be absurd
to say that an electron
sitting on this polymer chain
in response to this field
would be constrained only to
flow in the direction of the
chain and would find it rather
difficult to hop from one
chain to another.
So maybe, just maybe, we could
apply an electric field to a
polymer and it would have a flow
in this direction, that
would be pointing in this
direction, and the current
flow, J, would be in
that direction.
So should we maybe rethink this
idea of the direction of
the generalized displacement
being not parallel to the
direction of the generalized
force.
OK, these are hypothetical
examples.
Let me now give you an example
of a real property for a real
material, for which the thing
that happens, the vector that
happens, is decidedly not
parallel to the direction of
the applied vector.
OK, thermal conductivity is
something that relates a heat
flux, usually represented by the
symbol K, and relates that
to a temperature gradient,
dt dx, which is a vector.
The thing that gives rise to
thermal conductivity can be
either propagation of radiation
as in propagation of
light traveling through a
transparent material.
But the other mechanism for
thermal conductivity is modes
of lattice vibration.
When a material is hot, the
atoms are jiggling around and
you can make the displacement
of an individual atom be
represented by a sum of waves
moving in all different
directions with a variety of
wavelengths in a variety of
amplitudes.
Take all those waves, add them
together at a particular time,
and you get the displacement
of the atom.
Propagation of heat by this
mechanism, by modes of thermal
vibration, can be very, very
anisotropic and probably the
best example of this is--
get a single crystal
of graphite.
And have the layers, the
graphite sheets, which are
hexagonal rings in which each
carbon has three neighbors,
and have the sheets be parallel
to the surface of an
extended two-dimensional slab.
Now we can't do that.
Single crystals of graphite
don't occur
in sizes like that.
But what you can do is make a
material called pyrolytic
graphite that you make by having
a reaction in the vapor
phase and having the soot that's
formed settle down onto
a substrate.
And what happens is you nucleate
a graphite crystal in
one orientation, and that grows
preferentially with its
layers parallel to the surface
on which it's nucleated.
And these nuclei occur
at random.
So you get a bunch of single
crystals of graphite, which
all have their layers, their
three coordinated layers at
parallel, but they
are oriented at
random about their c-axis.
And that's a material that's
very easy to prepare.
And it's called pyrolytic
graphite, and it has
interesting applications
and properties.
OK, now I'm going to suggest an
experiment to you and I'll
caution you, please do
not try this at home.
Get yourself a piece of
pyrolytic graphite.
Put a Bunsen burner
underneath it.
Play the Bunsen burner on the
bottom of the sheet of
pyrolytic graphite.
And to determine temperature,
we'll take a ball of cotton
and put it directly
above the flame.
And then take another ball of
cotton and put it down at the
end of the sheet.
If you do that and bring up the
Bunsen burner, this piece
of cotton will sit there
and sit there and sit
there and sit there.
And this piece of cotton will
instantly burst into flame.
So here's a case where dt dx,
the thermal gradient, points
in this direction.
And the heat flow goes off in a
direction at right angles to
the temperature gradient,
almost
exactly at right angles.
It turns out that the thermal
conductivity in this
direction, the value
of K in the--
I want to put crystallographic
directions on this.
But K parallel to the layers
is equal to 10 to the third
times K, perpendicular
to the layers.
So there's an anisotropy of the
property that amounts to a
factor of 1,000.
Very dramatic.
So what I'm leading up is that
in a general relation between
a generalized displacement, p,
and a generalized force--
I'm sorry, I'm using
q-- p and q--
we just can't simply put
some constant in front.
Because that assumes inherently
that the direction
of what happens, the vector
that happens, is exactly
parallel to the direction of
the applied vector and that
generally is not true.
The difference may be small but
it has to be taken into
consideration.
All right, let me now suggest
a way of patching this up.
What I'm going to
do is assume--
and it is an assumption--
we're going to assume that each
component of the vector
that happens is given by--
in fancy terms, the vector
that results as the
generalized displacement is
given by a linear combination
of every component of the
vector that's applied.
And that's what we've defined
as the generalized force.
So how would we express
this analytically?
I am going to use as my
coordinate system, not x, y,
and z as we usually do,
I'm going to call
it x1, x2, and x3.
The reason is we'll see some
unique properties of these
indices that are very useful
algebraically.
So I'm going to now take my
applied vector, p, and I'm
going to assume that it has
three components, p1, p2, and
p3 along x1, x2, x3,
respectively.
My coordinate system, although I
did not state it explicitly,
is going to be a Cartesian
coordinate system, not a
crystallographic coordinate
system.
So what I'm proposing here is
that we take each component of
the resulting vector q--
let's say q1--
and we'll assume that that's
given by a linear combination
of all three components
of the vector p.
So it'll be some number times
p1 plus some number times p2
plus some number times p3.
And those numbers in general
will be different.
So let's say I call the
coefficient a, and now I'm
going to define a convention
that will stay with us.
I'm going to define each of
these coefficients, a, in
terms of the index of the
component of the generalized
displacement which is being
computed, and the coefficient
modifies the component of the
generalized force for that
particular term.
So I'm going to call this a11,
where the 1 goes with this and
the 1 goes with this.
I'm going to call this a12, so
that the 1 again says it's a
contribution to q1.
The 2 says that this
term modifies p2. .
And this similarly
would be a13.
For the term component of the
generalized displacement, q2,
I'll use the coefficients a21
times p1 plus a22 times p2,
plus 23 times p3.
And q3 similarly will be a31
times p1, plus a32 times p2
plus a33 times p3.
So I've got three simultaneous
equations then, one for each
component of the vector that
results, the generalized
displacement.
So I can sum up this set of
three equations by saying that
the i-th component of q, where
this is some particular
component, q1, q2, or q3, is
given by the sum over j from 1
to 3 of aij times p sub j.
So I've got ai1 times p1, ai2
times p2 plus ai3 times p3.
So this is in a nice, compact
little nugget the expression
that we are assuming will
apply for all sorts of
physical properties in which
this is a vector
and this is a vector--
electrical conductivity,
magnetic susceptibility,
thermal conductivity,
and so on.
OK, this is a bad point to
introduce something as hairy
as what comes next.
But I've got one minute left,
and I think I can do it.
I'm going to introduce something
called the Einstein
convention after old Albert
Einstein himself.
I'm sorry, but nobody
said everything this
term had to be easy.
So let me introduce, if you're
ready for it, the Einstein
convention.
Old Albert, I think, was just
as lazy as anybody else.
And he said it is going to be
a bloody pain in the butt--
I don't know if he put
it exactly this way.
It's going to be a pain in the
butt to write this summation
every time we want to combine
three terms in a linear
combination.
So the Einstein convention is
let us throw out the sigma and
write this expression just
as qi times aij p sub j.
And whenever we see a subscript
repeated, summation
over repeated subscript
is implied.
OK so that's the Einstein
convention.
It will save us the trouble
of writing in a lot
of summation signs.
But I would caution you that
this convention, compact and
convenient as it is, can define
some polynomials that
are nightmares.
So let me give you one example
of this, and this is actually
a physical property.
Let me say that Cijkl is given
by ai capital I aj capital J
ak capital K, al capital L times
let's say D, capital I,
capital J, capital K, capital
L. That actually, believe it
or not, means something
physically and we're going to
get to that in due course.
But what this is, taking the
Einstein convention into
account, this is a quadruple
summation over capital I,
capital J, capital K, and
capital L. These are very
often referred to in this
business as dummy indices,
meaning that they don't really
mean anything physically.
They're just indices
of summation.
I would caution you that
this is a term
that does not permute.
If I say those are dummy
indices, it means one thing.
If I say those are indices,
dummy, it means something
completely different, and
you're apt to get
a poke in the nose.
OK so these are dummy indices.
Now, what does this represent?
I won't say what it represents
physically, but this consists
of terms in four variables
times a coefficient.
So there are five quantities
in each term.
If I sum over capital I, J, and
K from 1 to 3, there are
going to be 81 such terms,
each with five
elements in each term.
So it's going to be on the order
of 405 terms in this
summation, and we've collapsed
the whole thing down, 405
terms in this nice summation.
So it is a great facility for
writing down expressions
explicitly, but these terms can
hide a terribly, terribly
complex polynomial.
All right, I think that's
a good place to quit.
It continues to amaze me,
though, how some absolutely
trivial convention, when first
proposed by a great man, will
carry that man's name no matter
how stupid it is.
So this is called the Einstein
convention by everybody who
works in this field.
Another one, just briefly to
finish up, when you discuss
dislocations, you talk about a
circuit of steps around the
dislocation.
That's called a Burgers
circuit.
And if you do the same circuit
in a corresponding piece of
material that doesn't have a
dislocation, if this circuit
closes, this circuit fails to
close by something that's
called the Burgers vector.
Every book on dislocation theory
says, Shockley called
this good material.
I'm sorry, Shockley called
this good material, and
Shockley called this
bad material.
Big deal--
good material, bad material
because it's got a
dislocation in it.
But that is identified with
Shockley's name in every
discussion of dislocation.
I'm just jealous because nobody
has ever said according
to me, such and such is--
all right, see you
later in the week
for more great things.